marie vastel ottawa bonsoir à vous on
est heureux de vous retrouver
donc ça alec castonguay à montréal
toujours fidèle emmanuel et michel c
avait été pris dans les sentiers de
cette campagne fort longue
alors voilà et oui le niqab
on avait presque premier de ne plus en
parler ici à ce panel mais monsieur
après on leur parle et on fait écouter
un petit extrait c'était aujourd'hui on
vient tout de suite
le gouvernement du québec le
gouvernement libéral du québec déposé un
projet de loi de loi devant l'assemblée
nationale qui demande quand brevet de
l'identité quand un livre aux cancres
soir des services publics c'est aussi
simple que ça nous avons indiqué que
nous examinerons cette loi avant de
déterminer les prochaines étapes
mais le gouverneur du québec le
gouvernement libéral du québec agit
d'une façon très responsable nous sommes
capables de faire la même chose à ottawa
alors marie vastel corrigez moi si je me
trompe mais il n'était jamais allé aussi
loin dans le modèle du québec le projet
de loi québécois voilà ce qu'on pourrait
devrait peut-être faire donc il continue
à parler de ceux-là oui tout le monde
est tanné d'entendre parler du niqab
sauf stephen harper parce que ça l'aide
énormément donc ils arrêtent pas
stratégiquement de ramener le sujet sur
la table et je noterai que sa réponse
était volontairement flou andy powell en
dit pas non au niqab dans la fonction
publique on dit qu'on regarde québec qui
a fait de façon responsable et convoque
peut-être s'en inspirer et monsieur
râpeux a pas été très clair de quels
aspects de sa réponse se référer à
s'inspirer du québec et ce que je note
c'est que en coulisses le parti
conservateur dit que monsieur a peu
parlé de s'inspirer du québec pour la
façon responsable d'agir pas pour
l'interdiction du niqab dans la fonction
publique sauf que comme ça la range d'en
parler comme ça la range d'avoir l'air
de de sévir sur le port du voile
intégral
sa réponse était volontairement floues
et il ne le peut pas corriger non plus
et donc je pense que c'était tout à fait
fait exprès mais aujourd'hui toutes les
manchettes le décide de nouvelles évoque
la possibilité que monsieur un peu c'est
vite jusque dans la fonction publique
même si je n'ai pas l'impression que
c'est réellement leur intention d'aller
aussi loin que c'est ce que vous avez
vous avez raison dans son entourage
certains dit attention là on n'est pas
en train de dire qu'on va légiférer là
dessus mais on n'a pas mis des mots dans
sa bouche il en a parlé donc il sait que
c'est payant
mais en même temps c'est glissant canada
anglais alex parce que ça là si on parle
de tous les services publics des
fonctionnaires c'est la charte et là
c'est tout un gros débat qu'on nous
remettons aussi un peu dans le contexte
lorsqu'elles veulent la charte de la
laïcité ou la charte des valeurs du
parti québécois le gouvernement harper
était farouchement contre toute
initiative allant dans ce sens là je me
souviens jason kenny qui était ministre
à l'époque et qui est encore aujourd'hui
au gouvernement harper qui disait on va
poursuivre le gouvernement du québec
devant les tribunaux pour les empêcher
de mettre en application la charte est à
ce moment là des bêtes tuées québec
après ça en mars dernier vous avez eu le
jugement donc sur le serment de
citoyenneté avec le niqab on a posé la
question à tony clément qui président du
conseil du trésor qui est patron des
fonctionnaires est ce que vous pourriez
à l'éventuelle mans jusqu'à bannir le
niqab la fonction publique comme vous
voulez peut-être le faire pour le seul
match qui est dit pas du tout on veut
pas là c'est une question charte le
gouvernement ne dit rapport à ses
employés commencent à blyes ain est pas
question
on y six mois plus tard on est en
campagne électorale et soudainement on
est en train d'étudier la question
peut-être que c'est une bonne idée on
vous dira pas ce qu'on veut faire
si vous rajoutez à cela le fait que le
syndicat de la fonction publique
canadienne dicter à notre connaissance
il n'y a aucune femmes qui portent le
niqab en public jersey ropa 2.40 québec
n'ont plus passé on se retrouve donc
avec un des bottes tombe à moins de deux
semaines de la campagne électorale et
que stephen harper juge très payant dans
la grande région de québec au saguenay
là où il est en train de faire une
remontée est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
va légiférer là-dessus d'accord avec
marie moi je suis loin d'en être
convaincu là donc on ne veut pas laisser
mourir le sujet on veut qu'ils vivent un
peu une dizaine de joueurs quoi encore
mais en même temps le danger c'est
d'ailleurs peu trop loin et marie
oui sauf qu'en même temps je dirais que
même au canada anglais la base
électorale du parti conservateur je
pense en grande partie est d'accord avec
cette interdiction du niqab
parce que c'est la première fois que
monsieur un peu a évoqué l'idée de ou a
pas fermé la porte à interdire le niqab
dans la fonction publique c'était sur
les ondes de cibl ici hier chez vos
collègues anglophones la question lui a
été posée il a du maire on va voir ce
qu'on va faire
s'il dit en anglais à une chaîne
anglophone d'après moi c'est parce que
c'est pas uniquement payant au québec et
monsieur un peu le sait a écouté
apparent du niqab il a remonté
énormément au québec mais lui aussi a dû
premier au canada
possiblement terrain majoritaire donc je
pense que c'est payant partout mais on
va en reparler des sondages marie
justement et alec on va vous montrer des
tableaux on en parle depuis plusieurs
semaines mais là ça se confirme c'est
extrêmement serrée entre les libéraux et
les conservateurs vous dites
conservateur premier celui là c'est
l'abacus d'aujourd'hui qui manque les
libéraux premier mais là on est dans la
marge d'erreur 33 avec da contre 30,2
pour les conservateurs le npd qui a été
distancé à 24 en ontario regarder le
chiffre c'est important pour les
libéraux trancou neuf on s'approche du
40 en ontario qui est un chiffre magique
où les circonscriptions peuvent débouler
conservateur 32 en ontario 23 parlons de
celui-là l'abacus ça montre donc ils
sont nés année là conservateurs et
libéraux
c'est redevenu alec une course à deux
presque c'est une course à deux ans
nombre de comtés qui va se jouer région
par région parce que même les chiffres
en ontario sont fort intéressants voyez
32 39 30 2 puis 23 ou 24 pour le npd à
la grosse bataille actuellement elle se
rejoue dans les banlieue de toronto dans
ce qu'on appelle le 9 05 c'est le code
régional des banlieues toronto glotte un
outil extrêmement féroce entre parti
libéral parti conservateur ya beaucoup
de compter dans cette région là et ils
sont les deux très très élevé dans les
intentions de vote alors que le npd pour
un facteur dans les banlieues toronto il
ya certaines circonscriptions on pense
qu'ils vont récolter 8 9 peut-être 10%
seulement or donc le 23 24
le npd il est posé
les faibles encore à en raison des
banlieues de toronto mais il est
beaucoup plus fort dans le nord de
l'ontario le npd me faire des gains dans
le sud de l'ontario lho l'industrie
automobile et menacée par le partenaire
transpacifique le npd peut faire des
gains aussi donc c'est vraiment le 3
août à rioz séparer sans compter le
centre de toronto le cnp des libérales
comme lutte alors même les chiffres en
ontario certainement une vaste province
en vain une circonscription saccage des
sous batta élections vont être fort
intéressante à regarder le 19 6 contre
et marie les autres soirs c'est votre
premier soit avec nous m'ont dit cette
campagne heures en fou à les maisons de
sondage là parce que c'est extrêmement
serré et ça se joue de façon régional
différemment oui exactement je suis
d'accord avec alex est difficile aussi
de lire les sondages parce que comme tu
es avec la dynamique est différente par
tout aussi d'ailleurs on n'a pas
toujours le découpage par compte et donc
est ce que le npd peut venir brouiller
un peu les cartes et les conservateurs
se faufile l'ontario est quand même
énormément sillage c'est là que les
consommateurs ont gagné leur majorité et
donc faut voir aussi ce découpage sur le
sud ouest de l'ontario c'est vrai que
monsieur lucas pourrait peut-être
ramasser des des appuis avec sa position
sur le partenariat partenariat trans
pacifique parce qu'il a décidé de
défendre coûte que coûte les travers de
l'industrie automobile mais cela dit
heureux braquant a dans ses vieilles
habitudes à gauche
le npd a quand même froisser certaines
personnes qui avaient été séduites par
son recentrage donc on sait que le [ __ ]
est un peu en espèces de paiement
expression damage control et est donc
aucun doute pas mais on exactement aux
gangs quelque part mais il a peut-être
qu'on entend par ailleurs et je vous
dirais que dans les coulisses du lpb
chez des gens qui y ont travaillé on est
un peu déçu de voir que pendant deux ans
on a beaucoup misé sur le québec peut
être pris pour acquis les 58 sièges
qu'on avait gagné au québec sans pâtir
des appuis deux ans en avance par
exemple en ontario où on en avait
énormément besoin en 2011 dont le
gagnant cinq sièges en ontario de plus
qu'avant c'est pas beaucoup et pourrait
probablement les perdre on va voir en
terminant rapidement le
la noce canada québec canada libéral
encore devant depuis trois jours il met
les libéraux devant conservateur à 30 de
très très près encore hélas une paix des
23 au québec les libéraux s'est étonné
reçoit 27 27 % 26.5 les conservateurs à
18 et le npd à 30 toujours première un
[ __ ] et le bloc à 21 il faut toujours
faire attention le dis à chaque fois
mais c'est des petits échantillonnage
pour chaque province là les chiffres du
canada sont plus plus sûr même si ceux
là on les mettait en doute que ceux du
québec
mais quand même les libéraux ont remonté
au québec alec libéraux ont remonté au
québec c'est assez clair bon ils sont
différents à différentes positions en
fonction des sondages persécuter le i3
sondages le qui ont des chiffres
complètement différent québec depuis
hier l'abacus de ce matin dans leur
école de cet après midi puis c'est le
nan associe les trois son petit peu
différents endroits le plus clair si
c'est la lire
mais effectivement une constante là
dessus vous avez raison patrice libéraux
sont un peu plus forts depuis maintenant
quelques semaines c'est assez concentrés
dans la région de montréal
chez les anglophones et les allophones
pour l'instant donc en termes de nombre
de sièges c'est pas énorme
on peut faire quelques gains évidemment
l'on s'entend alors que la répartition
du npd chez les francophones et plus
forte donc ça maintient le npd à un
niveau assez élevé au québec l'on parle
de commander des maisons de sondage du
programme à 102,35 est encore 45 sièges
au québec et libéraux sont plus entre 15
et 20 comme bracket mais c'est clair que
il ya certaines circonscriptions où on
pensait que le npd les faire un des bons
résultats on allait avoir une bonne
lutte avec les libéraux par exemple dans
l'antique mélanie joly maria mourani là
il semble que mélanie joly va
probablement l'emporter parce qu'avec
des chefs comme ce jeune dj ousmane dit
ben ça va favoriser les libérant le site
de compter leurs maris le bloc n'a pas
dit son dernier mot non plus n'ont
visiblement ce que je dirais c'est que
je me demande peut-être pas montréal
mais mais ailleurs cette remontée du
bloc si faible soit elle s'enlève quand
même surtout des appuis au npd
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'aucun
concrètement en termes de sièges 2 qui
remporte le siège ça aussi à mon avis
c'est une grande variable marie vastel
ce plaisir on vous retrouvera un
certainement alec castonguay à demain
vous devrez vous
être ici tous les jours merci puis
rester on va parler du canadien après
dany dubé est avec nous merci messieurs
dames salut